turning overseas President Biden is in
Finland this morning celebrating that
Country's new membership of the NATO
alliance which might never have happened
if Russia had not invaded Ukraine now Mr
Biden's visit follows a NATO Summit
where leaders welcome Ukraine's
president and promised him more Military
Support
Ouija Zhang is in Helsinki she's
traveling with the president is here to
bring us up to date wiesha good morning
to you
Gail good morning to you and good
morning to everybody Finland here has an
over 800 mile border with Russia and it
is moscow's invasion of Ukraine that has
dominated President Biden's meetings all
week long today he will meet with Nordic
leaders to continue that high-stakes
conversation
we will not waver A Renewed message of
NATO solidarity and support for Ukraine
now more than 500 days into its war with
Russia
President Biden denounced Russian
President Vladimir Putin in front of a
cheering crowd of nearly 10 000 in
Vilnius when Putin and his Craven lust
for land and power unleashed his brutal
war on Ukraine he was betting NATO would
break apart but he thought wrong strong
words came with strong assurances from
the U.S and other G7 allies promising
Ukrainian president zielinski long-term
security guarantees zielinski in a
meeting with President Biden explained
how urgently assistance is needed you
spend this money for for not not just
for father you spend this money for our
lives meantime at least one person is
dead after Russian forces used
iranian-made drones overnight to bomb
buildings in Kiev
Russia is warning the U.S after its
decision to send cluster Munitions to
Ukraine a controversial weapon banned by
most of the world
the Kremlin also voiced opposition to
Nato leaders opening an eventual path
for Ukraine to join the alliance after
the war is over I hope we finally have
put to bed the notion about whether or
not Ukraine is welcome and NATO is going
to happen President Biden's trip to
Helsinki has a starkly different tone
than the last time a U.S president
visited this city it was back in 2018
that then president Trump seemed to side
with Vladimir Putin over the U.S
intelligence Community about Russia's
meddling in the 2016 presidential
election Tony
Finland for us would you thank you very
much